おおぉー
わかった！（ガタッ）
勉強頑張れ！
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
えー2年前やったと思うんですけども覚えてますでしょうか
［拍手］
ウェー
確か前回やったのが
これまで買って来たAmazonの物を
全部見るっていう動画を出したんですけども
もう2年も経ったんでまた結構な量を
Amazonで買い物したわけでございますよ
今回はそれを一つ残らず皆さんに紹介しようと思います
あの僕基本的にネットで買い物する時
Amazonでしか頼まないんで
僕がネットで買った物は全部
Amazonだと思っていただいて結構です
え、待ってやばいのとか買ってそうだなぁ
いや、いいんですよその生々しさがきっと
いいんだろうね
はいというわけで今回も包み隠さず
ここ2年間Amazonで買ったものを全部見せます
あのーまじで全部見せますからね
えーまず基本的にもうね多分ねー
あのー遊戯王カードしか買ってないんすよね
あとあれだ割れない鏡買って
これ買えば多分誰にも負けないと思ったんでしょうね
あとなんかなぜかスピーカー買って
Roomba買ってるね
YouTuberマガジン vol.2買ってます
あ、また遊戯王カード　遊戯王カード
シャワーにつけると炭酸で
シュワシュワーって出ると思って買ったんですけど
また遊戯王カード
遊戯王カード買いすぎだろ　また遊戯王カード
ここでなんだこれ
あ、あれだ
塩、なんかお塩を飛ばすショットガンをここで買って
皆んなに撃って嫌がらせをしてました
また遊戯王カード
あーアクアボール買ってそれ用のエアーポンプ買って
全身タイツを4つも買ってますね
ポータブル電源　あっゲーミングチェア買って
でここで机を買ったが何かを思って返金する
次水素ロケット
サーキュレーターをなぜか2つに分けて10個買ってます
あっここで掃除機を…
なんで俺掃除機2つ買ったんだ
また遊戯王カード　また水素ロケット
あーここら辺なんかパソコンに目覚めたんでしょうね多分
でパソコン買ったついでに
デスクも買おうかなって思って多分デスクも買った流れ
また遊戯王カード　また遊戯王カード
ん？
買ったんですけど怖くて多分使わなかったやつですね
また遊戯王うぇ遊戯王買いすぎ
あ、ここで理香様のあの写真集を買いました
よかったです
また遊戯王　遊戯王に戻っちゃった
えー俺本当にやばいなー
バカなんじゃないの
どんだけ遊戯王しか買ってないの
やばっ
あっここでなぜかいきなり
外付けハードディスクを３テラ分買ってます
あ、また遊戯王
あっここで綱引ロープを
さんじゅう…え？待って俺どんだけ買ってんのこれ
え、俺動画に使ってないよね
やばい、記憶にない
なんでこんなに綱引ロープ買ったんだ
多分でも計算すると30メートルを34個なので
1000メートルにして何か綱引しようとしてたんでしょうね
あーこれ電撃が流れる目覚まし時計
花火の火縄だけ買って
あとIVIS（アイビス）カメラですね
いたずらグッズ買って
PokemonGoのあの腕につけるの買って
また遊戯王に戻って
いやほんとに好きだなぁ
で、ファイナルファンタジーの映画を買ってますね
あっハリーポッターのねあの被って
あのどこの寮に入るか決めるやつがあるんすよ
グリフィンドールかハッフルパフか
レイブンクローかスリザリンか
ハリーポッターの衣装買って
iPadのケースを買って
また遊戯王に戻って下駄を買いますね
でアルミケース買ってガシャポンマシーンを
やっとちょっとYouTuberらしくなってきたんじゃないでしょうか
あ、デスノート買ってますね
どこいったんだぁ
え、俺使ったけなぁ記憶がもうないんだよな2016年の
本当遊戯王すごいな
あ、ここでエビの着ぐるみを買ってますね
へへｗｗ
待ってワッフルタンクトップ買いすぎでしょ
なんで最後だけ返金した
多分買いすぎたと思ったんだと思います
で靴とおばけえび飼育セット買ってたなぁ…遊戯王
夢をコントロールできるアイマスクも買って
キーボードと机とまたIVIS（アイビス）を買ってる
砲丸をここで4つ買ってます
バカですね
ここら辺からなんかね
マンガを読み始めたんすよねAmazonで
生贄投票っていうマンガを読んで
ここら辺からマンガにハマりだしたんだよな確か
え、待って待って俺何買ってんだこれ
で浴槽のバスタブを新しく買って
でカメラのことをちょっとちゃんとしようと思って
防湿庫を買いました
サンタクロースのコスチュームを爆買いし
トナカイを買い花火を…
ここら辺も遊戯王関係 靴！
ドクターマーチン買ってますね
う〜ん　なぜか2016年の最後に
年末で自分頑張ったということで
靴をたくさん買ってます
はい、では2017年見て行きましょう
なんでお正月から自分のマンガ5冊買ってんだ
お正月から遊戯王のやる気がすごいすごい
やる気しかないやんけ
あっやべっ
あの…ふっ
はい
終末のハーレムっていうマンガがなんかすごい…
ハーレムで
よ、、よかったです
ここでGoProを買ったんすよね
ちょっとなんかあんま使ってないんだよな
遊戯王の福袋くじ買って
レーザーポインター
バスケット、バスケット欲がここでちょっと出ちゃったんでしょうね
けどすぐ遊戯王に戻ってしまいました
あっこのクロニクルって映画すごい面白かったです
パチンコ玉1000個買ってますね
なにやってんでしょう
2000個買ってんじゃん
ラーメン食いたくてラーメンTシャツ買い
やっぱえー？
ここら辺からなんか映画に興味を持ち始めてんのかな
UFOソープポンプを3つ買ってます
あっ
懐かしいねぇ
あのボージョレ・ヌーヴォーを買ったんですよ
これなんかボトルがすごいグニャンってなってるから
うわっすげー曲がるなんか
ここら辺が多分曲がる関係で一緒に買ったんでしょうね
また遊戯王買いドローン買ってますここで
iPhoneケース新しいの買いまた遊戯王
もう基本的には　コバラサポート買ってる
基本的にもう遊戯王しか買ってないのかもしんないな
観葉植物を爆買いしブロックも爆買いし
巨大なエンターキーを買いまた遊戯王を買ってますね
そうだなんか電子ピアノを買おうと思って
電子ピアノをここで買って
360度カメラも買ったけど結局使うことなく
電撃殺虫ラケットをもう売っている分全種類買い
フェイクダイナマイトを買い
ゴールデンタイムのマンガの9巻だけ持ってなくて
それだけ買いました
失恋日記っていうマンガを買い
あーでも遊戯王関係がやっぱ多いよね
学校の怪談4を見てます
ゼルダの伝説の一番くじのＤ賞をわざわざ買い
で、ゲーミングチェアをまた買い
あ、ここら辺ちょっとまたカメラのやる気が出て
うわすげーな結構ここら辺YouTuberっぽいな
なんかシゲキックスを爆買いし
日焼けしたくないんですけど日焼け止め塗るのも嫌だったんで
日焼け止めの飲むのを買い
また備品を買ってるな虫のおもちゃいたずら…
ファイアパンチっていうね
マンガすごい面白かったんっすよこれ
なんだろうなんか最近マンガにハマってんなこの時期
なんかナイフ頭に刺さってる　ペヤングを買い
なんかここら辺なんか痛々しい気持ちになったんでしょうね
でここで電子タバコを買いクモさんたくさん買い
ここでのぶこを買ったんですよべんちの
そっかーもうのぶこがきて1年になんのか
今地下で寝てます
シャーペンここで買ってんだ
ジェノサイダーってなんだこれ
やべーまたなんかちょっと…
ちょいエロのマンガを読みがちなんですよ
血が出るカプセルピルを買った後に
ギャクマンガ日和ですかねこれは
ギャクマンガ日和のアニメを見た後に
エウレカセブンを確か一気見したんすよねここら辺で
エウレカセブンうわっめっちゃ見てんな
多分夏なんで蚊に困って蚊とれ〜るを買い
また再びエウレカセブンに戻り
エウレカセブン見まくってこのまま最終回まで見てしまった流れですね
ゴキブリここで買いまくってＳＤを買い
なんかまたYouTuberっぽくなってきたところで
突然の映画ブームがまたきます
デジモン見てデジモントライを見て
バイオハザードをみてラ・ラ・ランドをここで見たんすね
甘城ブリリアントパークっていうなんか遊園地を経営するアニメにハマってまた見てます
で、はとしの服
なんだこれなにこれ
いっｗ稲川淳二の心霊通信見てますね
あま、甘ブリは面白かったっすよ
でホーム、なんか君の名む（？ ）
たまごかけごはんカメラ買って
コンテナ買いだしていきなり
で、とらドラですね多分とらドラ見て
そっかカードを整理しようと思って
遊戯王カードを買いすぎたじゃないですか見たとおり
だから遊戯王カードを入れるための
なんかこういう大容量の本棚を買いました
なんかグレネードを手にし
三ツ矢サイダーを買いまた遊戯王を買いまくり
ここでこたつです
なんかこのなんかおしゃれなメタリックのゴミ箱を買い
恐竜になりたかったでしょうねハロウィン
ハロウィンなんかね恐竜になって街で暴れようと思ったんですけども
間に合わなかったので諦めた思い出があります
また遊戯王買ってる
うわっまた遊戯王熱が出てきて
おっ　っとっと
（ガタン）
はぁ皆んな勘違いしないでくれ
動画コンテストにあってそれで
あのーＪＫたちが出演して欲しくて
あのーその子たち用に制服を買ったんですよ
決して
僕の趣味では
ありません
あのこれあ言ってなかったんですけど
デュエルマスターズちょっとやろうかなと思って
デュエマにちょっとだけこう手出しちゃったんすよ
でもやっぱり遊戯王が良かったみたいですねー
で、割れないコップを買い
レジを買いますね
で、アイスクリーム買ってんなこれ
学ランがいると思って学ランを買ったりして
鋼錬の服ですねまぁ結最近だろうこれもう
ベイビー・ドライバーっていうですねあのー
映画がすごい面白かったんで
是非とも見ていただきたいです
えーイルミネーション爆買いしクリスマス向けの動画を作って
ここでAirPodsを買ってますね
去年の最後はAirPods買って終わってんだなぁ
これはあの僕の分とだいちくんの分買ってました
はい、では2018年です　2018年まずは…
手始めにサッカーあ、これなんか Fischer'sやってたな
これ買ったんすけどなんか…微妙だから
そのままお蔵入りにしてしまいました
で、望遠鏡を買いチーズを買い
なんかなぜ、なぜか服に目覚め
で、めぐみちゃんここで買ったんすね
そっかー今年買ったのかめぐみちゃん
これ1冊買うとマスターボールがついてくるんすよ
でここでエロマンガ先生を買い
服が欲しいと思ってナノ・ユニバースの
福袋みたいなのを買ってお正月を過ごしてました
サッカーボールを買い空気（入れ）買い
また遊戯王時代がきて
またGoPro買ったんですけど
なんか色々あってやめて遊戯王に戻り
七つの大罪を見まくってますね
二期が始まったんだ
七つの大罪の二期が始まったから
見なきゃと思ってこっからまた見始めました
また遊戯王買い
あっさりりんのね、さりりんの写真集を
買ったわけですよSKEの
あの友達に配るために4冊買いました
中にね限定で入ってる生写真だけは
僕が回収しました　ありがとうございます
ここでちょっと落し物がひどいっていうことに気づいて
忘れ物をしないために紛失防止タグってのを買いました
これをどこかに失くしました
また遊戯王に戻りマンガを買い
GoPro今度正式にHERO6を買い
フェイクピアスをたくさん買って
あっ、血界戦線にハマったわけですよ
めっちゃ面白いってかテンポがいいってか音がいい
ってかなんか空気感ってか雰囲気が好きです
空気清浄機を買いまくり花粉の季節になったから
でまたちょいちょい七つの大罪とかを見ながら
ドクぺを爆買いして
で、こっからっすねちょっと畑が始まったんで
なんか全員分のMacBookを買ったりしてました
で、こう皆んな分かりやすいようにカバーとかも買って
ベイブレードに再びハマりだし、なんか変なカードゲームを買ったりして
ギャクマンガ日和にまたハマり
あーちょっとネタバレに
ちょっと今後の動画のネタバレになるものがあるので
ちょっと隠しながらいきますね
またカメラを買ったりして
こんなもんかなぁ
（笑い）
この犬の顔すごいすよね
はい、こーんな感じでございます
とりあえずちょっと見てみてわかったことは
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】